there are numerous supernatural beings
and races that make an appearance in
Irish mythology sometimes members of
these races may be described in a
similar manner to a god and other times
they may appear as a creature a monster
or quite often just as a human we've
previously discussed the two added annan
one of the very first supernatural races
to settle in Ireland but today it is the
sworn enemy of the two at a Denon FIFA
mauryans that would be the subject of
the video we for mauryans in the Tour de
denon of the two predominant
supernatural races that appear in Irish
mythology so it makes sense at some
point in time these two races were
locked in a wall to decide who ruled
over Ireland
despite the hostility between the two
races they were still known to
intermarry and have children similar to
what we see in Norse mythology between
the Norse gods and the odhner
there is a very clear distinction
between the characterization of both
races the Tour de Danone are often shown
to represent growth and civilization
whereas the four mauryans or gods and
creatures associated to have darkness
death and the destructive qualities and
powers of nature this definitely
manifests itself in the physical
appearance the two added N&R very
similar to human in appearance but the
four morons on the other hand come in
numerous shapes and sizes they often
appear as small to medium-sized
creatures with deformities that
sometimes resemble goblins or other
mischievous creatures but if we break
down the meaning of their name perhaps
we can understand how they were
originally viewed by the Irish in old
Irish the word foe was thought to mean
below beneath or lower the word more
meaning great or big derived from an old
irish turn that was thought to describe
a demon this fueled the belief that the
four mauryans may have been large beings
or creatures that came from beneath the
ground or even the sea I do personally
like these interpretations of the four
morons as they have quite a lot of
crafty and feel to them
regardless of their size it was quite
common for the former in civvy described
or depicted as having a variety of
deformities be it missing or additional
limbs a hunched back or a body covered
in large warts and pustules the husband
some debate as to who the first settlers
of Ireland were with many believing it
to be the forum or Ian's if we follow
the medieval myth of path alone who
arrived in Ireland with his people three
hundred years off the Noah's Flood when
they eventually settled with for more
Ian's already there the 17th century
historian Jeffrey Keating believe that
the for morons arrived 200 years earlier
led by keyhole creer host and survived
mostly on a diet of fish which could
contribute to their association with the
scene the people of path alone would
eventually go to wall of the for
Maureen's in the Battle of my Eve the
first battle of Ireland according to the
labore Gabara Ln the book of a taken of
Island three hundred four morons took
part in this battle and along with their
leader they were all slain there are
some contrasts in details regarding the
location of the battle and how many for
morons were killed they all seem to
agree that the battle was won by path
alone and his people the people of path
alone would prosper for hundreds of
years before they would eventually all
die of the plague despite losing the
battle the four mauryans were the one
constant fact in Irish mythology many
races invaded Ireland but the morons
were always ever-present in the
background when the two added an
undefeated the theater bulk their first
king in Ireland was breast who was half
for more in the result of a union
between arrow and a firm Orion Prince
Ella thaw both Ella firm breasts were
described as being extremely beautiful
contrast him from the appearances we
described earlier brush however turned
out to be quite a questionable King
forced in the Tour de Danone to work as
slaves paying tribute to the four
mauryans
he would eventually be the throne to
lose all authority fleeing to his father
asked him for help in restoring his
kingship his father refused to help him
as he thought he was an unworthy king
with no other options breast turned to
Bal or a fist for more in war chief with
a large eye in the middle of his
forehead that when opened caused untold
destruction
Paulo agreed to help breasts and
together they raised an army to
challenge a two at a tenon for the rule
of island the Tour de denim would be led
into battle by another half Amorian Lu
whose mother was battles daughter this
battle would be referred to as the
second battle of my to-read the firm
Orient's been led by below and the to a
Danann by Lu the current king of the
Tour de nan Nevada would be slain in the
battle when Balor opened his poisonous
eye killing all those are gazed upon him
Liu would eventually come face to face
of his grandfather and when Baloo
attempted to open his eye blue drew he
sling and fired of rock driving bellows
I threw the back of his head and
destroying the majority of the four
Mauryan army behind him after suffering
such a devastating blow the for morons
were defeated and driven back into the
sea over time the meaning of the word
for Mauryan changed to instead to refer
to pirates or Seabourn Raiders the for
morons such an interesting race because
they can literally appear as anything
gigantic monsters small agile creatures
with unique deformities or just as a
handsome prince they have quite a close
link to the two added annan as they
descended from the same God and as we've
seen quite a few noticeable figures in
the 2d Danone are actually half form
Orion I'd love to know how you picture
the four mauryans do you see them as a
hold of demonic creatures that came from
underground perhaps as Giants that rose
from the sea or maybe a mix of both let
me know in the comments below as always
I've been your host ecology and fiction
explained